this is a Wendover productions video
made possible by audible so I recently
went down the rabbit hole of looking at
old flight schedules airlines used to
publish these physical brochures with
their fares and flight times and when
looking at this american airlines one
from 1967 i noticed something
interesting the flight between New York
and LA was scheduled as 5 hours and 43
minutes long that didn't seem right
American flight 3 was scheduled to leave
JFK Airport every day at 12:00 noon and
arrive at LAX at 2:43 p.m. there's three
hours time difference it turns out that
nowadays American Airlines flight three
still leaves JFK daily at noon but the
difference is that today flight 3 is
scheduled to arrive at LAX at 3:27 p.m.
44 minutes later than in 1967 this has
happened across the board almost every
flight today takes longer than it did
back in the 60s in general the actual
flight times the time in the air is the
same but with all the congestion and
delays at airports the scheduled times
now account for things going wrong what
this means though is that overall flying
has slowed down in 1967 we hadn't been
to the moon and computers look like this
but we were flying everywhere just as
fast or even faster than we do today
what happened that causes immense lack
of progress in the last 50 years if
there are three main types of aircraft
engine the turboprop turbofan and
turbojet and each of them has a range of
speeds when their most efficient the
turboprop is the kind of engine that you
see on most propeller aircraft almost
all the thrust with turboprop engines
comes from the propeller the turbine
which spins the propeller does intake
and speed up some air but the exhaust
air is not at a very high speed so it
only accounts for less than 10% of the
overall thrust these engines are
generally inexpensive both to buy and
operate so a lot of smaller commuter
planes use turboprop engines of course
there's a trade-off there not as fast
their most efficient between about 325
and 375 miles per
our any faster than that and it's better
to use a turbofan now these are the
engines that you see everywhere almost
every commercial aircraft is turbofan
driven with turbo fans the air is
initially sped up by a fan that's what
you see when you look at the engine from
the front then some of the air goes into
the internal combustion chamber where
the actual turbine that drives the fan
is and the rest of it goes around the
turbine while air that bypasses the
turbine is also sped up the majority of
the thrust comes from the air that
passes through the turbine turbo fans
are most efficient at the speeds that
you see in most aircraft flight today
400 to 620 miles per hour if you want to
go supersonic
above seven hundred and sixty seven
miles per hour you need a turbo jet
turbo jets are very similar to turbo
fans except all the air goes to the
turbine no air is bypassed this lets
them achieve extremely high speeds but
they also require an immense amount of
fuel these engines are only really
efficient between about 1,300 and 1,400
miles per hour what really determines
the efficiency of engines is something
called the bypass ratio that's the ratio
of the amount of air that passes through
the bypass duct to the amount that
passes through the engine core the thing
is it really doesn't take that much more
energy to spin a larger fan what
requires a lot more fuel is to put more
air through the engine core that means
that engines that accelerate more air
through the bypass duct can get more
thrust for the same amount of energy so
as a rule the higher the bypass ratio
the more efficient the engine take a
look at this General Electric gen-x
engine this is a relatively new super
efficient engine used on both the 787
dreamliner
and the 747-8 eye you can see that the
fan is much larger than the turbine
itself that's because this engine has a
bypass ratio of 10 to 1 10 times more
air because of round the turbine and
through it compare that to the CFM
International cfm56 an older and less
efficient engine you can see there's
much less fan relative to the turbine so
this engine only has a bypass ratio of
5.9
one but that's still considered to be
high the difference is most striking
when comparing either of those engines
to the pratt & whitney jt8d this engine
as a bypass ratio of only 0.9 6 to 1 so
it's astoundingly inefficient but it's
still significantly more efficient than
the rolls-royce Snecma olympus 593 this
engine is a turbojet as I mentioned
these drive all the air the fan picks up
through the turbine and that means that
no air is bypassed therefore it has a
bypass ratio of 0 to 1 and is what's
known as a zero bypass engine since 100%
of the air passing through the engine
goes through the turbine the fuel
consumption is significantly higher than
that of the gen-x cfm56 or even the jt8d
the concorde using the zero bypass
rolls-royce Snecma olympus 593 burn
forty six point eight five pounds of
fuel per mile flown while the 787
dreamliner using the ten to one bypass
ratio General Electric gen-x uses
eighteen point seven pounds per mile but
the Concorde was a tiny airplane even
compared to the modestly sized 787 it
seated only 100 passengers compared to
291 on the Dreamliner that means that
the per person fuel economy on the
Concorde was just about 14 miles per
gallon compared to 104 miles per gallon
on the Dreamliner in the end Air France
and British Airways the only two
Concorde operators could not afford to
keep flying the plane less than
one-third of the seats were actually
occupied by paying customers
others were filled by those using miles
or those upgraded from first class on
normal flights after all
it cost and a minimum 7,500 of today's
dollars to fly one way from London to
New York in those three hours and that
was to fly in seats that looked like
this not all that different than the
economy seats of today when the Concorde
started flying first class on other
planes looked like this while nice these
seats were just larger economy class
seats and it wasn't incredibly easy to
sleep in them by the time the concorde
stopped flying in 2003 first
class look like this and the seats went
fully flat into a bed many chose to
spend a little less to pass seven hours
in this rather than spending three hours
in these cramped seats British Airways
even introduced a first fully flat
business class seat in 2000 so for
significantly less money than the
Concorde travelers could cross the
Atlantic sleeping horizontally this just
wasn't luxury anymore the whole idea of
the Concorde was to create the most
efficient way to cross the Atlantic for
the business traveler but with fully
flat beds those travelling towards
Europe could leave the u.s. in the
evening get their night's sleep on the
plane and wake up in Europe essentially
wasting no time no longer luxurious or
efficient the Concorde flew its final
commercial flight on October 24th 2003
thereby ending the era of commercial
supersonic flight here's the thing about
flying speed really doesn't matter to
Airlines it really only exists as a
selling point for the consumer the cost
of the airplane is a relatively small
part of the overall cost to fly so
you'll never see an airline fly faster
so they can use their planes more planes
lifespans are generally rated in cycles
the number of times the plane takes off
and lamps the Dreamliner is rated for
44,000 cycles and has a list price which
is often much higher than the actual
sale price of two hundred and twenty
four point six million dollars that
means that the cost of the airplane per
flight is barely over five thousand
dollars while the fuel costs for a
flight from New York to London is well
over fifteen thousand dollars therefore
Airlines always just fly their airplanes
at the most fuel-efficient speed it
turns out that that speed is just about
always between 500 and 550 miles per
hour
what's weird about this is that it's
well below the speed of sound 767 miles
per hour
why don't planes fly just below the
speed of sound well this graph shows the
drag on airplanes at different speeds
between Mach point 8 and Mach 1.2 is
what's known as the transonic range at
these speeds the airflow around an
airplane is not fully subsonic or
supersonic essentially some air is
subsonic and some is supersonic so
beginning at Mach
point-eight some airflow becomes
supersonic which increases drag
exponentially and destabilizes the
aircraft so it's actually quite
dangerous to fly right around the speed
of sound you either have to fly well
above or below you can actually see when
an airplane is flying transonic it's
hard to see but there are these lines
that look like scratches on the camera
lens but are actually many supersonic
shockwaves because of the disturbances
in the airflow flying between Mach point
8 and Mach 1.2 actually requires more
fuel than flying above Mach 1.2 so
that's why we have this number six
hundred and thirteen point eight miles
per hour that's the speed limit for
commercially viable subsonic jets while
supersonic flight and crossing the
Atlantic in three hours is flashy and
exciting which truly impressive is
hopping the pond for 100 or 200 dollars
on an airline that's actually making a
profit and that's becoming more of a
reality today with current speeds
airplanes are able to fly anywhere on
earth in 24 hours and that's fast enough
for almost everyone the barrier to
travel for most people is cost not speed
so manufacturers and Airlines will
continue to focus their efforts on
driving down the cost of travel not the
time in the end time is the enemy of the
privileged view cost is the enemy of the
masses this video was made possible by
audible audible is the leading online
audiobook provider but I'm sure you
already know that what I'll tell you is
how I use audible I love reading
but there are a lot of times when I just
can't read a paper book when working out
doing dishes even when editing a video
so I download tons of audio books
through audible so I can learn no matter
what I'm doing if you listen when doing
tasks like me you're turning what is
normally something boring into something
fun I recently started listening to sky
faring a book by 747 pilot Marc van den
Acker it gives a glimpse into the pilots
side of flying but it's written much
more like a novel or memoir than a
heavy-duty nonfiction book the great
thing is that you can listen to this
book for free thanks to audible with a
30-day free trial you get by signing up
using the linked audible.com slash
Wendover it's a fantastic book and
audible is a fan
sztyc site so please do at least give
them a look over at audible.com slash
wound over other than that you can
support Wayne over productions at
patreon.com slash win over productions
follow me on twitter at 1-over Pro watch
my last video about how the president
travels here check out my fan moderated
subreddit here and most of all subscribe
to this channel to receive all my future
videos right when they come out thanks
again for watching and I'll see you in
two weeks for another Wendover
productions video